the 90s were amazing here's why the
movie is set in the year 1969 and we are
shown the final stages of the Vietnam
War during this an American Squad member
named Luke Devereaux receives an order
to secure a village against North
Vietnamese forces under the heavy rain
Luke heads towards the village only to
discover a grim sight in his fellow
Squad members and several innocent
villagers lying Dead with their ears
brutally mutilated Disturbed Luke enters
a shack and finds his colleague Sergeant
Andrew Scott who has gone completely
insane he has made a necklace of severed
ears and you can bet your sweet ass he's
gonna drop a fire Pawn about them at
some point and is holding a young couple
hostage Luke tries to reason with Andrea
claiming that the war is over however
Andrew gets infuriated and executes the
boy in front of him he then orders Luke
to shoot the girl in order to prove his
loyalty the latter obviously refuses
saying that it is inhumane when Andrew
proceeds to do it by himself Luke tries
to run away with the girl however Andrew
shoots Luke in the leg and throws a
grenade at the girl killing her
mercilessly so excessively the
confrontation escalates into a deadly
exchange of gunfire between Luke and
Andrew resulting in both of their deaths
the next morning an American Special
Forces Squad finds their bodies the
commanding officer orders the bodies to
be bagged and iced and to never discuss
with anyone the truth of what really
happened their disappearance is
classified as missing in action the
scene then cuts to the present day in
1992 when some terrorists have taken
over the Hoover Dam the situation looks
intense as the lifeless bodies of
civilians are scattered along the Dam's
roadway some surviving civilians are
held hostage and one man is shot dead by
the terrorists who press for their
demands to be met meanwhile the deceased
bodies of Luke Andrew and some other
soldiers are re-animated and selected
for the universal Soldier or uni Soul
this stupid short form program on Elite
counter-terrorism unit these soldiers
are administered with a neural serum to
maintain the susceptibility of their
minds and keep their past memories
suppressed following this these uni Soul
God are deployed to the Hoover Dam to
resolve a hostage situation amidst this
commotion a TV news journalist named
Veronica Roberts arrives at Hoover Dam
to cover the story and may I just say
damn but since she is late again she
ends up being fired from the job later
as the uni Souls infiltrate the area
they demonstrate their Superior training
and physical abilities one of them even
survives close range automatic rifle
fire the unisole team proceeds to
eliminate the terrorists one after
another eventually securing the area a
short while later Luke begins to regain
memories from his past life upon seeing
two of the hostages who resemble the
villagers he tried to save back in
Vietnam turning around he looks upon the
face of Andrew who also appears to be
experiencing the same memory but as a
uni Soul he doesn't utter a word this
distraction causes Luke to freeze and
ignore radio commands from the control
team outside Colonel Perry who is in
charge of the unisole project addresses
the news reporters and gives them some
vague answers this awakens Veronica's
curiosity so she decides to sneak into
the base with a cameraman in order to
gather first-hand information back in
the mobile command center the unisole
technician team is trying to figure out
what happened at the Hoover Dam incident
then the unisoles are revealed to be
genetically augmented Soldiers with
enhanced self-healing abilities and
Superior strength however they also have
a tendency to overheat and shut down
because of the glitch one of the
technicians on the project Woodward
suggests that they remove Luke from the
team however Colonel Perry tells them
that the mission will proceed as and
insists on injecting the serum on the
other hand Veronica sneaks into the base
ignoring her cameraman's warnings she
makes her way inside and soon comes
across a damaged uni Soul seemingly
wounded but still alive believing that
he's dead Veronica begins taking
pictures but he suddenly wakes up
freaking her out freaked me out too this
causes her to set off an alarm prompting
them to be spotted as a result Luke and
Andrew are ordered to capture her dead
or alive Veronica immediately runs and
gets in the car with her cameraman to
escape however they sadly meet with an
accident ultimately getting captured
later Andrew demands the return of the
camera and when Veronica refuses he
mercilessly shoots her cameraman this
action prompts Luke to regain his
memories again without thinking much she
then intervenes rescues Veronica and the
two manage to escape in a uni-soul
vehicle seeing this Andrew mumbles to
himself softly about Luke being a
traitor but none of the uni salt team
realized it upon learning about the
Escape Colonel Perry sends the remaining
Unisource to find Luke and Veronica he
fears that the concept of uni Souls will
be exposed to the public and American
government because the nature of the
project is still unknown by those wimps
at the Pentagon while driving away
Veronica notices Luke bleeding and
urgently searches for a way to stop it
to her surprise he sterilizes it with
the car lighter Midway on the road the
car runs out of gas so Luke starts
pushing it at a surprising speed leaving
Veronica in awe they managed to reach a
gas station but unfortunately it is also
out of gas and the public phone isn't
working with no choice the duo decides
to rent a motel room and spends their
night there upon entering the room
Veronica turns on the television and
sees the news of herself Being Framed
for the death of her cameraman amidst
this Luke starts to heat up so he takes
off his clothes and stands in front of
an air conditioner
however this doesn't help and he
eventually collapses due to overheating
the little old lady across the streets
watching that
upon witnessing this Veronica takes him
to the bathtub and fills it with ice
this allows his wounds to heal in a
rapid manner puzzled by what she has
witnessed Veronica heads to the
reception to call the doctor but she
fails the uni Souls seem to have
sabotaged all of the communication lines
unbeknownst to Veronica and Luke the uni
Souls have already tracked their
location shortly after the duo are
conversing in their room when they are
suddenly attacked by the uni crap name
they start running from room to room by
crashing through the walls freaking out
all the other Motel clients especially
the naked ones at one point they hide
themselves under a couple's bed there
they hold the couple at gunpoint and to
demand their car keys which allows them
to flee the United Soul unit sees the
car leaving and opens fire regardless
Luke drives through the reception and
the two get away the following day on
the road Veronica begins asking a lot of
questions but sadly Luke doesn't
remember anything if you want to make
Jean-Claude seem like a good actor just
make him a zombie with brain damage not
long after they pull over at a gas
station Luke leads Veronica into a room
asking her to check and remove any
tracking system implanted in his body as
she does so Veronica finds a compass
pointing true north then finds a Tracker
in his leg button refuses to hurt him as
a result Luke uses a knife to make an
opening himself Veronica is grossed out
but still inserts her fingers into the
wound to remove the tracker following
this they set a trap for the uni Souls
when the attackers breach the room a
fire erupts leading to an explosion at
the gas station that was a real ass
explosion as a consequence the unisels
are engulfed by the Flames taking
advantage of this distraction Luke and
Veronica sneak into the unisol team's
vehicle steal a bunch of files and drive
away from the scene just then Andrew
suddenly appears in the back seat and
starts choking Luke this leads him to
lose control of the car causing it to
crash the impact sends Andrew flying
through the windshield whereas the other
two are saved by their seat belts
enabling them to Get Away safety first
in the aftermath of this event Colonel
Perry is ordered to terminate the
mission so he instructs everyone to get
back on the vehicle however Andrew's
Madness resurfaces leading him to kill
the colonel and everyone else sparing
only the two doctors afterwards Luke and
Veronica sit in a restaurant where the
latter tries to decode the information
in the stolen files during this she
notices a recurring name Dr Christopher
Greger prompting her to question Luke if
he knows anyone with this name Luke
responds boom upon further investigation
Veronica discovers Dr greger's phone
number so she steps out to call him
while she's away Luke draws everyone's
attention in the restaurant by consuming
an excessive amount of food a
confrontation ensues when the owner
questions his ability to settle the bill
the owner tries to punch him but Luke
easily Dodges and defeats him with one
kick other men in the diner try to go
after him but he beats all day asses
Veronica notices this from outside and
hurries to take Luke away on the other
hand the technicians advise Andrew to
cool down as his motor indicates
overheating while in the cooling chamber
the two technicians plot to administer
the serum to knock Andrew out however as
one of the technicians walks in Andrew
senses something is amiss and he
brutally injects the technician with the
same serum killing him an apple a day
keeps the doctor away later in the
evening Andrew goes to a bar and
inquires about Luke and Veronica a local
man makes fun of him bad idea and Andrew
Beats him up terrifying everyone into
answering his questions back in Andrew's
truck the last technician instructs a
uni soul to hold a grenade which results
in a blast within the vehicle however
Andrew doesn't give up he takes two uni
souls to a store's freezer in an attempt
to revive them but his effort proves
unsuccessful in the morning Luke and
Veronica meet Dr Greger who is the
originator of the program the doctor
tells them about the history of the
program and how it was aimed to develop
the perfect Soldier the only problem
with it was that the memories of the
past lives became greatly Amplified Dr
Greger explains that Andrew is stuck in
a delusion believing that he's still in
Vietnam fighting insurgents during this
Luke suddenly recovers memories of his
past and expresses his desire to go home
and meet his family in Louisiana just
then they hear on the news that Perry is
dead and they're blaming Veronica for
this one still following this Veronica
suggests that they expose the uni Souls
project but Luke is already tired the
duo then steps out of Dr greger's Place
only to be surrounded and arrested by
the police in the next scene the two are
being taken away in the police Convoy
but soon after Andrew and a United Soul
gr-76 starts chasing them in a truck he
shoots the officers and kills the bus
driver cause using the bus to lose to
lose troll remember kids this is the
days before CGI this scene is Bonkers
after a while of chasing Andrew starts
yeading grenades and going whoa yay yeah
oh yeah then the police bus and the uni
Soul truck both drive off a cliff just
before the vehicle plummets off Luke
manages to kill gr-76 and jump away when
the other cop from the Convoy shows up
Veronica knocks him down and the duo
takes his car to escape then Luke and
Veronica head back to Luke's family farm
in Louisiana unfortunately Andrew still
manages to track them down he reappears
at their location and takes Luke's
family and Veronica hostage following
this Luke confronts him leading to a
fierce fight between the two Andrew's
use of muscle enhancers enables him to
mercilessly beat Luke's ass meanwhile
Veronica uses the sharp spikes of a hay
Harvester and manages to free herself
from captivity she then attempts to
escape but Andrew throws a grenade just
like the beginning as the battle
continues Luke manages to get a hold of
the muscle enhancers and he injects
himself with one now evenly matched Luke
starts fighting back with his newly
found strength soon after he manages to
impale Andrew on the spikes of the
Harvester and then activates it
shredding him to pieces your discharged
Sarge in the aftermath Luke releases his
family before venturing to the explosion
area he finds Veronica who has survived
the blast although sustaining some
injuries the movie ends as the two of
them share a romantic hug Luke is still
just a zombie with half a brain but that
ain't gonna stop Veronica from tapping
that subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching